have you seen how tall
baron trump is yes this guy's okay 6 10.
this guy is a 14 year old my daughter is
the exact same believe this picture by
the way
he was born in april of 2006. he's 14
years old he's 14 years old he's an nba
player
at this point go to that picture go to
the rnc
because that's when we got to see him in
public and really how tall he was
right there left i mean he's taller than
donald go to that one
this is oh my god go to the one they're
in front of the white house there you go
right there kyle hey you're on it kyle
you were just honestly kidding me no
pat i spent the day with melania one
time she's 5 10.
right there okay there you go okay the
one in front of the white house buddy
holy
i mean donald trump is six two he's six
three
wow that kid's at least six six that
that
height is helped by melania oh yeah
that's simple because she's 5 11. so
uh uh uh the other ones are are shorter
i don't know how tall
ivana is and i don't know how tall
here's my prediction
that kid and he's going to be the center
for the mavericks
in seven years is going to be the
starting center for
the washington dc uh was it the
washington wizards
he's going to be wearing a black lives
matter shirt he's been playing in the
nba
his father is going to be absolutely
disgusted
i hate you dad you raised me the wrong
way you never were there for me
for whatever the nba seven did that
happen yeah obviously
for whatever i just don't see that
happening with my family so pat when you
mention that you know donald says
at the age of 21 is when i take over as
a dad yeah so now you go to that go back
to one so in other words when they come
in for the job interview
he's interviewing for a job tell me a
little bit about yourself look at the
size of him
that's right i don't know nothing about
my grandkids how tall is he pat give it
i mean if donald six two six
three how tall is that kid he's six five
you know what six
five the same jacket yeah that's right
you guys have a similar jacket
zippers except the other way a 14 year
old's jacket by the way look at his eyes
he's got swagger he knows who he is yeah
he knows who he is you know
they're doing a good job of keeping him
under the radar screen and kudos to them
for doing that at the age of
why do you say that because you don't i
when i saw everybody was astonished how
tall he is meaning we never see him
so great job not having a mom in public
yeah i see what you're saying that's a
good point
he's complaining that his knees were
hurting the other day i'm growing i'm
getting taller i remember when i grew
nine inches in a year and my back and my
knees were hurting non-stop this guy
must have literally grown
did you let her and i grew nine inches
in one euro wow
yeah nine inches on one euro look at
that no that's double the size of mike
pence
you know who else did that anthony davis
for the lake
that's why he was a point guard yeah he
was a point guard from his sophomore to
junior year in high school
that video right there kai oh my wow guy
go up to the video right there boom
hit that they both stand up at the same
time
stand up mike
you know he's like hey what's up minnie
mike how's it feel today he left the
screen
he was so tall his head is above the
screen are you kidding me
i can't get past the fact that baron
point is six six at 14 years old he
doesn't even fit in the picture
yeah but he stands up okay you're right
he is six six oh my goodness
yeah you guys matter in the nba six
yeah i mean uh by the way i'm telling
you imagine if he plays for the maps and
my math signing cuban
signs trump to play and he comes in
wearing a mega hat to the game and they
banned the hats you know
unbelievable somebody asked a question
the other day on twitter from uh
cuban they said hey is our nba players
allowed to wear mega hats and are they
allowed to wear
you know make america again and the
response you should have seen it it was
very interesting he says
well we have cops that work here that
are trump supporters cuban gave that
answer
and but the reality is i've not seen one
nba player wear a mega hat and you
cannot tell me a hundred because they're
afraid
fear there's no way in the world a
hundred percent
of all nba players don't support it
imagine they would be
no way in the world i literally think
that you're saying that there's a
few nba players that do support even
it's not even a future but they're
frightened
if they do and there might be i would
say ten percent well and there's going
to be some that would surprise you that
support him i guarantee you about taxes
well here's the other thing when they
say
get out and vote get out and vote what
if you say i'm gonna go vote
not the way that you're encouraging me
to by the way baron davis or baron uh
baron trump
if he did go to the nba he'd be taking a
pay cut probably so maybe he might not
do
not only that they'd probably take his
knees out every single night he'd be
like getting hurt
morris would be going for his knees
every single day he's going for people
it was just an accident
[Music]